okay Victor yeah for Wagyu beef or wait
table one yeah all at the same time to
rise to vegetables and cheese yummy
yummy yes yes thank you
come on look at me I always just take a
grip solid hold those reins yeah and get
this thing back on track yet make sure
every plate is absolutely perfect please
do your mother sat out there you know
that don't you yeah okay for bit please
stop by nice now
let's go please let's go okay me alone
thank you thank you excellent Gordon
just shall the nerves and then know what
I need to do you and you have come back
strong and they've got that focus going
on now
plate after plate on Victor's
mouth-watering beef is finally been
served
the Pope said yqv
a [ __ ] a fetus - where gender what do
you think completely melts in your mouth
Elizabeth I'm really proud of my dad and
my brother for just getting this far and
what they've cooked today is being
amazing in a kitchen they're not so used
to as well our kids are definitely done
as proud not said well yes yeah sure
let's go home the Shankill yeah chef
Jeff's mother yes yes service is over
and it's time to discover what my
distinguished guests think about these
two extraordinary dishes starting with
Victor's let's see well thank you very
much this is a real treat
I was working wonderful we were so
tender and special it worked very well
the Wagyu beef shows us extraordinary
you like nobody I've ever tasted before
the you and you will have more authentic
flavors me cayó dish not only the
presentation but the flavors it's much
better as well I think it was the better
dish mainly because of the tenderness of
the beef the accompanying dishes
particularly the rice that the rice was
outstanding my diners comments are
testament to the incredible standards of
both KY and you and use food but this
competition is about more than just one
dish
both these fantastic Chinese restaurants
have had their ups and downs throughout
this heat but now it's time for me to
choose between them meaning today is
very important for me because I really
want to be a proud to my family as a one
of a
top my turn each other in London but if
I'd be guys if they don't believe I'm
and there's such a fantastic restaurant
their dish is unbelievable you know so
we can only see you know we'd be it
would be unbelievable
only one of them can go through to the
semi-finals I've got to make a very
difficult choice